you know the low was a much
different breed of animal you know like
it you know it was you could very easily
get hurt you could get hurt either place
but there were guys that have life
sentences that been working out for 20
years and were just super angry you know
at the medium and and if you got hurt at
the medium it was probably really go bad
uh as opposed to you get hurt at the low
it's more like a a a fist fight in high
school so with knives so anyway I so I'm
there I'm writing I'm doing that
and it there was a guy on the compound
that came on the compound about that
same time his name was Frank Amadeo
Frank Amadeo is a a Rapid Cycling
bipolar with features of schizophrenia
Rapid Cycling bip polar with features of
schizophrenia Rapid Cycling it's just
constant right and so there are moments
in in His Manic state where he his
reoccurring psychosis I guess is uh that
he believes and since he was in his
early teens has believed that he is
pre-ordained by God to be emperor of the
world he's a lawyer despar stole close
to $200 million from the federal
government they gave him 22 years and
they sent him to
Coleman but it doesn't this is the part
I love the delusions don't affect his
legal
work doesn't say a ton for legal
Community but how do you know he's
delusional I'm just asking questions
yeah he's he's trust me I I I mean it's
it's not me it's like the transcripts
the lawyers the doctors the you know
yeah there's a ton of a ton and then if
you saw them in action you'd be like oh
wow yeah you know he'd be he would be
completely normal he would be having a
completely normal conversation
and somebody would say something and he
was he'd go that makes me so angry I I I
I can't I'm not going to let them do
that when my Legions March on
Washington we are going to burn the
Constitution and the president will
kneel at my
feet and he
goes I'm going to need your transcripts
I'm going to need a 2250 form we're
going to file a you and it would just
like and everybody would sit there and
be like okay Frank I'll get this and
I'll get it was insane it was the most
insane he was basically running a
medium-sized Law Firm from inside of the
prison he was training people he taught
the he taught
the um the legal research class and was
training people on how to do legal
research in prison how to put together
motions how to fight uh fight their
cases how to do the research how to type
them up everything he's teaching he's
teaching a law it's like a law school
right like he's teaching these guys he
he listen they made such a mistake
locking this guy up so he's a great
lawyer listen it's going to get worse
it's going to get worse because here's
what happens is at this point I don't
talk to him for probably a year or so
because everybody's saying he's crazy
you know and he's and for like a year he
gets there he's drooling out of the side
of his mouth they got him on a ton of
medication it takes them about a year to
get them to take him off the medication
so he he gets them to take him off the
medication and then he starts kind of
stabilizing his mood by drinking Pepsi
uh I know BR it's CRA I know it's crazy
I know how I see I see you looking at me
like this guy's delusion I know it works
whatever works so at some point one of
my buddies comes to me and says look you
got to go talk to Frank well here's the
other thing over the course of a year or
two that he's starts doing legal work
for guys he starts just taking on guys
cases I'll do the motion I'll do your
legal work I'll do this keeps them busy
but suddenly you start hearing people
get
released you know you know Jimmy just
got 10 years knocked off his sentence
he's going to halfway house next month
you know Tom got an immediate release
Frank's walking people up to R&D shaking
their hands guys are walking up to him
in tears crying and and so you know
crazy or
not what what choice do I have I I
called three different lawyers on the
street and said this is what happened
what can I do what can I do they they
had me they told me to do this and this
and this and I worked with them and then
they decided not to proceed and what can
I do and they said you're hit bro
there's nothing you can do you cannot in
the middle in the in the 11th circuit
you cannot force them to file a
reduction on your behalf you cannot do
it it's impossible you're hit you're
done it's over I'd love to take your
your money Mr Cox but it's not going to
happen I I can't I'm I'm just going to
take your money you're going to lose
three different lawyers I talked to I or
TI's lawyer told me bro it's not going
to happen it's over
so my buddy says go talk to Frank I said
well why why wouldn't I I got nothing
else to lose so I go talk to Frank he
actually has a little manic moment that
little thing that I just showed you
that's exactly what he said the first
time I talked to him based on your case
yes I won't let this happen he's like
I'm going to need your transcripts I'm
going to need to get this I need to see
your indictment I'm going to need your
prent report I'm going to need like okay
and I turned to my buddy he's like bro I
know I know what you're thinking it's
fine it's [__] crazy and he's like
he's like I understand let just what
what choice do you have I was like [__]
so Frank files a 2255 motion on my
behalf stating that I'm not time barred
that Millie
was we file it against Millie stating
that she was ineffective mhm right that
she didn't understand understand the law
she had me plead to something cuz she
thought I could get a reduction simply
for doing dat line oh by the way when I
was in the medium the government came to
me and asked me to be interviewed by
American Greed I do that I'm interviewed
you know they they they get me on the
phone they talk to me everything my the
prosecutor wants me to do it she's
reined everybody's reined it airs Millie
goes to them to the government says look
reduce the sentence they go no Millie
it's not enough then they come to me and
they ask me to write an an ethics and
fraud course I write an ethics and fraud
course the guy I write the course with
he they flies up to um Atlanta he talks
with I think he drove up but he goes up
to Atlanta he talks with the US attorney
talks to Millie she insists if he does
this I will reduce his sentence I will
definitely consider this definitely
consider yeah definitely consider and
then we do it it's being used all over
the
nation not enough consider that's where
at this point I go to Frank I tell tell
Frank what's happening Frank says yeah
this is he was every time they asked you
to do something it reset the time bar
you have a year from that time to file
2255 now he insists that that was a
viable argument nobody else does but he
said I'm not going to let them do this
I'm going to take care of this I'm gonna
get your sentence reduced
okay uh
Emperor okay Emperor
so he is a character uh anyway he so he
files 2
255 the government comes back they say
he's time barred Frank comes back he he
you know they answer his motion he files
a retort uh they file you know it just
goes back and this goes for six months
to a year and at some point I go to mail
call and you know they call my name and
they they hand me this thing and I open
it up and it says the government's filed
a motion for a stay so that they
can they want the court to appoint me a
lawyer and to discuss filing a rule 35
reducing my
sentence and I you know I like I read it
but I couldn't even understand like I
don't understand so I mean I rushed to
go find Frank I show it to Frank and he
says he says yeah they're staying it
they're going to send you a lawyer and
you're going to
negotiate for how much they're going to
reduce your sentence he said it's
perfect so they fly this woman down her
name is Esther pan
she flies down we comes to the
visitation room they bring me there the
lawyer's room whatever they call it the
and so we're sitting there and I
remember we're talking and she says uh
listen your your motion your 2255 is
written well but honestly you don't have
much of a
prayer and um they're offering you a one
level
reduction which is 30 months and I
went oh that's that's not enough and she
said well I don't know what to tell you
you um she said they're willing to bring
you back and I was like well you know I
mean I don't know I got to talk to Frank
Frank said I deserve this many levels
and know we're going back forth she she
goes who's Frank and I go Frank's the
guy that's doing all my legal work she
goes he didn't write all this and I was
like no she goes who wrote and I I
explain it to her and she's like he's an
inmate and I was like yeah and and she
goes why is he here and I tell her well
cuz he's he stole a bunch of money from
the federal government cuz he's trying
to take over the world so I tell her
that whole thing and she's like you're
letting
a a a mentally
incompetent you know person do your
legal work and I was like yeah because
all the competent attorneys wouldn't do
it they said I didn't have a prayer your
people said I didn't have a prayer and I
said Frank said he was going to he could
get this done and she's like well I
mean you know you don't like I don't
even know why they're offering you one
level I was like well Frank said you
know and I'm like Frank this Frank that
and so she I end up saying she's like
you're taking advice from a a legally an
incompetent person I said
yeah and she said you know you really
don't have a prayer I said then why are
you here I said if they could crush me
so easily why are you
here I said they're giving me one level
let me talk to Frank I'll let you know
what we're going to do so I leave I call
her a couple days later I tell her Frank
and I talk to Frank Frank said go back
go back and argue for more he said I
think the judge is going to give you
more he's going to give you at least you
know between whatever he said like six
or seven levers or something so I get I
get moved all the way back to
Atlanta the FBI agent comes to talk on
my behalf the guy that like multiple
people show up to talk on my behalf they
say you know Millie who I filed the 2255
against so I'm basically saying you're
you're ineffective you're incompetent
you know but she knows the game she's
like I get it she she gets on the stand
and testifies for me so the judge goes H
you know listen I think we were asking
for like nine levels or something
outrageous prosecutor starts arguing for
one
level and he said listen one level is
not nearly enough for what Mr Cox has
done he said Mr Cox I know you're
arguing for nine uh nine levels off your
send he goes that was never going to
happen was like felt like I got slapped
and he said so I'm I'm going to go with
six levels no no I'm sorry he said three
levels I'm going to go with three levels
he is which is uh which is seven years
which he said for somebody who has no
arrest associated with his case he said
I think it's pretty good and that's my
that's his judgment and blah blah blah
blah blah and he Hammer put puts the
gavel down and walks off that's it it's
over I got seven years I was hoping for
more so I get moved back to Coleman I
get moved back to Coleman and I go to up
to Frank and I said Frank I got I got
seven years off and he's like I know I
know I said I I don't mean to sound
unappreciative I said I
just said I was hoping for more he goes
I was too he said it looks like we're
going to have to eat this elephant one
spoonful at a time and he goes something
will come out something's going to
happen he said keep your ears open
something will happen and I said okay
and you know I Honestly by that point
I'd done you know I'd done eight years
and I remember like if I got a year off
for the drug program and good time and
this and I had about eight or eight
years left to go or something nine years
left and I was like you know I can do
that all right you know I'd been writing
um by that point I'd i' actually written
a
story like I got a book deal for
deoli you know um and I ended
up uh writing a synopsis of a guy's
story story and I got him in Rolling
Stone magazine and I got a book deal for
that like I got an advance it's like
3500 bucks for being in prison a
prisoner to get $3500 Advance like I'm a
millionaire he a lot of money so and
then we optioned the film rights
basically the synopsis that I wrote for
this reporter journalist for Rolling
Stone he goes to Rolling Stone with my
with what I wrote and gives it to them
and they okay it they say yeah this is
great we want you to write an article
based on this okay he writes the article
he tells
me that the article will be from him his
name gee Lawson Douglas Dodd which is
the name of the kid I wrote the Memoir
about and Matthew
Cox couple of weeks before it's going
the article is going to be published he
tells me rolling stone doesn't want my
name on the article because I'm in
federal prison and it doesn't look good
but don't worry he's going to put my
name in the article and that's just as
good um and I argue it's not just as
good it's not I'm like I would be I
would be a writer for Rolling Stone
magazine like you understand I'm trying
to I'm trying to come up with something
here that I can rebuild my life as a
true crime writer that's no
good what and that wasn't so bad that
wasn't the worst of the worst of it was
90% of the article that he published was
taken directly from what I sent him like
I mean sick to my stomach bro just sick
over it so but they option they option
the life rights for that and I got a
piece of that so there's like $7,000 I
get a check for that so I'm I'm thrilled
I can keep writing because you have to
understand writing on the computer there
they charge you so I start write oh they
charge it for phone calls writing
comment every single thing cost money so
I start writing all these guys stories I
start writing
books I just come back from went back to
Atlanta got re got sent seven years
knocked off my sentence come
back and I'm walking around the
compound now there was a guy that was
there named Ron Wilson Ron Wilson
ran in if you look in the newspaper it
says it's like a a hundred million Ponzi
scheme but really was $57 million so he
had lost 57 million so it says 100 you
know they you know always exaggerate cuz
57 is not enough Ron ended up getting 19
and a half years Ron was an old con man
mhm early 60s 62 61 I don't know and uh
Ron I and I liked
Ron
um so we're walking around the compound
and he's like so what are you going to
do me like eight or nine more years to
go and I was like H you know I'm going
to keep writing and when I get out of
here maybe I'll I'll have a huge body of
work and maybe I'll be able to sell it
or maybe I'll be able to option some
more stuff and if I could get together
with rolling stone or get with some of
these magazines I could start writing
for them and I could option those maybe
I could walk out of here with something
so right right right so Ron was who'd
only been locked up like a year or so he
was cooperating with the Secret Service
in his case against some of his
codefendants so he's he's already been
debriefed and he's cooperating he's
actually thinking he might get brought
back to have to testify at a
trial we're talking and we're walking
and he keeps saying you know even if I
even if they they charge those guys and
even if this happens they're not going
to reduce my sentence they're not going
to cut my
sentence you know first of all well
probably because you stole a bunch of
money from Pension funds and churches
that didn't help your case but I don't
say that uh so I I say oh they have to
Bro they'll have to they they you know
if you cooperate they're going to have
to and if they don't we'll have Frank
follow 22
255 and he's like uh ah that crazy
mother um so he says uh okay he's like
yeah yeah you don't understand you don't
understand so this goes on for
months and and I'm like what is the
problem and he says you know they think
I hid Ponzi scheme
money you know and he'd actually dug up
like five or six million dollars in
Ponzi scheme proceeds that he dug he he
he buried in these oh literally
literally buried in aluminum ammunition
canisters mhm super interesting guy so
he actually went and dug them up and
gave them to him and I'm like well you
gave them all the money it's you didn't
hide anything relax it's not a big deal
they're not going to find anything so
don't worry about it and so he mentions
it a couple weeks later couple weeks
later and then one day I go bro why do
you keep bringing this
up like what are you concerned about
they it's not going to happen and he
said can I trust you and I went probably
not not and he
goes I did hide some money I was like
okay I said you you bury in a can
somewhere and he's like no he I I um
gave my wife like 150,000 in cash I said
okay well she's not going to say
anything she's using no you don't
understand since then she found out I
was having an
affair and she we're going to get a
divorce and she hates me and I think
she'll turn that money in just to make
sure that I don't get a
reduction cuz if you lie to the FBI
they're not going to doesn't matter what
you've done for them they won't give you
anything and so he's BL I mean I'm sorry
Secret Service or anybody he is clearly
lied to the secret service at this point
if she goes and says this is what he
gave me MH so he's like I was like oh
wow and he's like and I gave my my
brother's holding maybe 30,000 for
me
and at that moment I was like wow
like this poor guy no that's not what I
thought at all what I thought was is
that enough to get me a sentence
reduction you son of a
[__] and I went and I sat there and you
know what I thought I thought I I I I
thought no I thought that's not enough
that's not enough it's nothing that's
not even
$200,000 like and they didn't want to
give me a reduction my prosecutor was
pissed that I got 7 years off she wanted
me to get 30 months she's not going to
give me anything it's up to her she's
not going to do it so I go I lay down I
go to bed like a month later I'm on the
phone with my lawyer because I had
written remember I wrote a man my I had
a manuscript for my book and I wanted to
put some of the stuff that was said at
my in my sentencing in the
book so I was trying to get my lawyer to
mail me my transcripts and she hadn't
done it so I called her and I said
listen you said you were going to she's
like oh God man I'm so sorry I'm so busy
I'll do it I'll do it and then she went
this is Esther her she was so what else
is going on in there and I this she
never wanted to talk to me like she
didn't you know when they were paying
her she didn't want to talk to me and
and I was like what do you mean nothing
I just need my transcription she's like
nothing's happening there's nothing you
want to talk about I was
like and I went you know
what you know what there's something
weird happened there listen to this and
I told her about Ron Wilson and she goes
hold on and she looks him up the
computer she goes oh wow this is a bad
guy
this is a bad
guy and he told you then you know where
it is absolutely she and I can tell you
exactly and she goes okay okay okay she
goes uh let me look into this I go okay
so a week later a a CO comes to me and
goes hey Cox and I go what's up he goes
listen at the next move because you know
they have controlled moves all the doors
are locked and they open them up for 10
minutes so you can run to the chow hall
or you can run to the you can't run
though there no running on the compound
but you can walk fast yes to the yard uh
or the library whatever he says at the
next move go to
sis you know so I go to Sis on the next
move but I was used to going there by
the way because I I was constantly
ordering Freedom of Information acts and
they would so I'd order your your an
inmate and I'd order I'm writing a story
for you and I'd order it and they'd send
it to me and then they would catch it
and they'd be like why are you getting
Lex's information so they call me down
there I go no I ordered it for him and
I'm writing a story and I'd already been
in Rolling Stone everything like what's
the story and I tell them the story they
that's a pretty good story here and so I
go down there but this is different this
the guy answers the door and his guy
they call him Bulldog he was a real
[__] uh he was a lieutenant sis and
he's like uh come in get in here Cox sit
down and he dials the phone he goes here
you got to talk to this guy and I'm like
what I pick up the phone I'm like hello
and the guy goes hey this is Agent
Griffin with the Secret Service I
understand you know where Ron Wilson is
has uh hidden Ponzi scheme money I who
whoa whoa whoa I want something in
writing I want you know so I start doing
that and they go okay I get his his
email address and we start emailing each
other back and forth and he ends up S
getting a letter from the US attorney in
South Carolina that says they will
consider it substantial assistance if
they if they make arrests or recover a
substantial amount of money MH that's
the best I'm going to get is consider so
I start talking this guy and he starts
asking me questions about Ron Wilson
like hey ask him this ask him this so
I'm like bro I got to kind of work that
into a conversation that's an odd thing
to ask this goes on for six months so
I'm asking questions and I'm typing up
little reports and I'm I'm a I'm a I'm a
prison snitch now so I'm not just like
cooperating I'm now I'm a prison snitch
so I've I've moved down I've moved down
actually from being just a cooperating
witness or because you're in prison is
that what makes you a prison snitch you
can't even really say um no you could
say prison rat you could say prison rat
I think prison snitch I think that's
probably the closer to the term that
most guys would use what's the
difference between a snitch and a rat in
prison I'm not sure I it rolls off the
tongue better prison rat doesn't sound
as good as prison snitch I don't know I
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
this so what happens is um I'm asking
Wilson questions periodically and at
some point they contact me and they say
listen Wilson's about to get some bad
news and I go
okay um and they go he's you know like I
would want to tell you what it is let us
know what happens it's like two days go
by and one day Wilson comes up to me one
day and says [__] [__] and I'm like oh
[__] I'm like hey what's up you know and
he's like oh my you're not going to
believe this I got indicted I was like
what what
happened no yeah my wife they questioned
my wife and my brother and my brother my
wife walked in first she said I don't
have nothing I don't know what you're
talking about the next day the brother
walks in and gives them
$150,000 in cash and so the next day the
wife comes back and gives them $250,000
in cash and a bunch of uh silver like
gold bullion and silver you know cuz
this he was a his his Ponzi scheme was
based off of
Silver you know he was going to invest
in silver for you so half a million
dollars they turn over half aill I'm
like half a million dollars I thought
she was like $1,000 or something and he
was he's like I know I didn't know I
could trust you I'm like
Ron what are you doing I thought we were
so he um so I'll tell you something just
for the icing on the cake by the way the
Cake Let Let Me Explain one more thing y
there's so if you're going to if
somebody cooperates with the federal
government let's say I get arrested and
they go you want to help yourself and
you go yeah okay um look uh Jimmy is a
he lives next to me and he's running a
meth house you know meth lab whatever
and they go and they raid Jimmy and he
gets arrested you're going to get
something off for that not a lot but
you're going to get
something
now and they could just say we were
going to bust anyway we were already on
to him right now the next level would be
you wear a
wire so I wore a wire and I I was in
danger now keep in mind I'm asking this
guy questions inside federal prison I'm
in danger so whatever that's like the
next level you're active you're taking
an active participate participation in
the um investigation MH and the third
level would be you actually get on the
stand and you cooperate operate and you
you testify that there's no better
cooperation than that
so when Wilson says to
me they're going to move me back to
South Carolina they've indicted me they
charged me what do you think I should do
and I go I think you should go to
trial because I know they'll have to
call me as a witness yeah just to let
you know because I don't I don't want
you to I don't want to walk out of here
and have you feeling
feeling like hey there's some there's
some good to this guy no so I'm ready
I'm I'm ready to cut Wilson like a fish
so yeah but you are putting yourself in
danger if you get understand right I'm
already in danger if if people there
heard what I was doing I probably would
have been in doesn't that increase the
chance of them hearing or no if you it
does but it also increases my ability to
get more off my sentence true so what
happens is couple days later he's on
What's called the pack out right they're
going to move move him maybe a week
later so they come and get him they move
him he gets back there to South Carolina
and he pleads guilty he he they sentence
him he gets six months added on so now
from 19 and a half to 20
years uh and and by the way when covid
hit he was released so he only ended up
doing like six years on a 20-year
sentence because he was older he's by
that point he's 66 67 years old you know
he's an old anybody older than 55 was
endangered especially in the prison so
they had a a CO thing where they were
releasing these guys and sending them
home on ankle monitors like he's an old
man he's not he he's not going to hurt
he's not he's not a
danger so they sent him home so he ended
up doing so he didn't even serve the six
months he even served the original
sentence whatever not that I care so I'm
just saying makes you feel like poor Ron
it's okay so his wife got like a hundred
year 100 she got like a hundred hours of
of community service or something or 60
hours and I think his brother got six
months papers they they got charged with
um obstruction of justice you know and
they didn't neither one of them you know
it's like six
months probation and community service
nothing so when we I turn around I'm
waiting for my reduction waiting waiting
after about 90 days after this guy gets
sentence maybe six months I send a
letter hey what's going on to the
prosecuting to my prosecutor their the
UT of both districts no response then I
go to Frank I explain to Frank and Frank
has known what's going on the whole time
and Frank goes uh okay I'm going to file
a 2255 so we file a
2255 government comes back and they
first thing they say is your honor we
don't know about any cooperation we've
never heard about any cooperation so of
course then we submit the letter that we
have the judge comes back and the judge
ends up saying it's a little complicated
but he ends up saying look I don't have
jurisdiction to hear this
because you're you may be time
barred but I'm going to let the the
appeals court hear it now typically you
have to you have to get what's called
like a right of cert a certification to
appeal you have to make sure that you
actually have a case he says I'm waving
the
CT and I'm waving the $500 fee to file
with them he said and I'm he's he
basically expedites it for me which is a
subtle way of telling the prosecutor I
think he's got something and I'm sending
it up there and he and the way he writes
his motion it's basically saying I don't
have the jurisdiction to hear to do
anything but they do they need to do it
and I'm Paving the way you don't have to
pay any money and you don't need that
sir so the prosecution immediately comes
back they file a a a one level
reduction and we immediately Frank file
something saying hey stop we don't want
the reduction we don't want the one
level we want to come back to court
please don't don't rule on it so the
judge says okay I'm freezing everything
I'm I'm putting a stay on everything I'm
going to give this guy a
lawyer to try and figure out which
you're going to do they fly down a
lawyer Leanne
Weber so she comes and and she comes and
sees me and uh she says listen I I I see
that you want to go back and fight this
and this but honestly I don't think
you're going to get anything more than
one level uh I talked to the prosecution
they said they'll give you well she said
I can work on trying to get you two
levels but you don't have much of a
prayer you're going to get crushed and I
said well then then why are you here if
they can crush me so easy why don't they
do it why would they pay you like they
pay them like 12 Grand or something just
to fly down and all your expenses to to
negotiate for me why not crush
me and she's like I I don't know I said
well Frank said four levels and she's
like who's Frank I go Frank's the guy
that wrote All This and she's like oh is
is he an attorney and I go is he in here
I'm like yeah he's in here she's like
why is he in here and I tell her he was
taking over the world yeah and she
says that's the strangest thing I've
ever heard my entire life and I said I
understand but Frank said and she's like
you're listening to an incompetent you
know I'm like
absolutely and she and Frank said four
level we want four levels she he said
for me to tell you we want four levels
she Sayes okay she leaves she goes to
the US attorney we argue two levels they
come back say two levels no we go back
and forth we start filing motion saying
we want to go back we want a hearing we
want to bring back all the FBI agents
the Secret Service agents and she's like
what do you want to turn this into a
circus exactly what do I want to do I
want to turn it into the biggest circus
cuz I've already got one
level they come back one day she says
listen three levels is the best you're
going to
get she said so uh I guess you'll be
moved back here we'll go to the hearing
I said no no no I'll take three levels
and she go what are you talking she said
you said four levels you said Frank
wouldn't take let you take anything less
than four I said no Frank said to tell
you four I was happy with three I wanted
you to argue for four I'm good with
three I'm out here in like a year yeah
so and I don't want to be moved back I
don't want have to get on that bus you
know what it's like to be moved it's
horrible so I said I just want the three
levels so then we argue about the
wording for about two three months and
then they file it and then I get five
years knocked off my sentence because
three levels at this at the level I was
at now isn't seven years every level you
get a little less time so I get five
years off so now I've got 12 years
knocked off my sentence at this point
I maybe have a year and a half to go mhm
and you know that's
doable so I was super super
happy
um and I'm gonna I'm going to tell you
something uh and I'm sorry bro um but
every time I think about it and I I just
feel like I have to say
it
like I'm Frank I'm insane
but I can like I didn't have a [__]
prayer without that guy and as crazy as
he is and much of a pain in the ass as
he
was um like I could never repay him bro
like like I'm not I shouldn't be here
I'm supposed to be in prison right now
my outdate was 30 was
2030 without that guy where is he now he
got himself out he didn't do all that
time he got himself out I don't even
know how he did it they even threw him
back in prison again for six months and
he got himself out again uh he's insane
he's incredible he's insane but he's
incredible is he really that insane he's
in
Orlando is he I mean he seems like he
seems like a good lawyer and a good man
he he's he's he's great he's great I
mean there's no doubt in my mind I would
be in prison right now it wasn't for him
and he's done this for others walk
people right out 10 years off 5 years
off 9 years off 10 years I mean it's I
didn't pay and I didn't pay for one
thing I didn't pay for my stamps he paid
for
everything sounds like the other lawyers
don't really believe it's possible and
he does it's interesting well I think
he's he was willing to he's willing to
Badger them into doing you know what
they should have done to begin with I
actually wrote a book about which he
loved about him about him and his story
his it's so overthe toop what happened
with him um I mean little it tried to
take over the Congo I mean there's a a
documentary about it there's it's called
nine days in the Congo it's an insane
story I'm I'm that's one of those
stories it's just like how is this not a
movie it's not a movie yet no I don't
I've pitched it several times and uh
it'd be it would be great but so I wrote
synopsis and I turned that into a book
what's the name of the book oh it's
Insanity it's Insanity yeah but about it
like a year and a half later like I
ended up getting out of prison and I
went to the halfway
house